im niedersächsischen stadthagen ist das
lusthaus im stadtgarten aufwendig
restauriert worden jetzt ist das gebäude
aus dem 17 jahrhundert wieder ein echtes
schmuckstück aber ganz gelungen ist die
restaurierung nicht denn direkt vor das
baudenkmal hat die stadt diesen klotz
gesetzt ein klo haus der blick aus dem
renaissance garten ist empfindlich
gestört
man hängt es etwas besser lösen können
aber ja ich weiß gibt der bürger gefragt
wurde die pc anlage gefällt mir gar
nicht sieht aus wie eine doppelgarage
und jeder privatmensch der so ein
schönes denkmalgeschütztes haus hat der
bekommt so ein unmögliches objekt davor
niemals genehmigt
seit den 60er jahren stammt dieser
zweckbau vor dem lusthaus nachdem der
anbau 2015 abbrennt dann schließt sich
die stadt die bausünde zu entfernen und
das historische gebäude zu sanieren
dies gelingt doch prächtig es ist heute
wieder ein echter hingucker
wäre da nicht die hässliche wc anlage
die die stadt mitten in dem historischen
stadtgarten gesetzt hat die toiletten
gehören zum kaffee im lusthaus aber der
klotz passt so gar nicht zu dem
denkmalgeschützten gebäude
vielmehr verschafft diese er fast alle
sichtachsen der bürgermeister hat
allerdings eine ganz eigene sicht der
dinge
man muss aber auch sagen wenn ich über
die achse gerade auf das lusthaus gucke
habe ich diesen blick dh verstellt wird
der blick nur dann wenn ich mich von
schräg links auf das lust hast stimmt
von links ist der blick übel aber von
der anderen seite sieht es auch nicht
besser aus satte 600.000 euro hat die
restaurierung gekostet und der
denkmalschutz hat den klub quatsch sogar
abgesegnet muss man insofern kompliment
machen weil eben auch praktisch mit
gedacht haben die haben schon gesehen
wir müssen irgendwo eine toilette haben
wir müssen irgendwie eine
gesungen haben und deshalb haben sie
dies auch mitgetragen
ein klo haus vor dem denkmal viele
stadthäger können sich damit überhaupt
nicht anfreunden
so wie es geplant hätte besser laufen
können da werden jahrelang arbeitskreise
gebildet und dann kommt sowas bei
rockstar kann man anschließend nun im
kopf schütteln
die stadt versucht nun zu retten was
noch zu retten ist der clou klotz soll
begrünt werden in der hoffnung dass
damit vielleicht gras über die sache
wächst